dacca yann moix âme
tu connais tout le monde presque par
mademoiselle david qui joue dans ce film
yvan attal ils se marièrent et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants qui est un gros
succès c'est même le seul succès du
cinéma français cet été faut bien dire
les choses internes et voilà tu connais
emmanuelle seigner oui bon choix a raté
un peu sous le charme quand même oui
vous savez longtemps c'est pas un scoop
à gatsby peine que je découvre je
découvre la fontaine pour un auteur
bravo dis-moi tu as vu une interview
d'agathe oui j'ai vu mais avant c'était
émouvant
les femmes blessées sont plus belles que
les femmes heureuses et voilà et voilà
dans sont les metteurs en scène aussi un
cours 101 la fin tu nous appelles podium
à six mois oui c'était jean paul rouve
julie depardieu et ça a fait 3,6
millions d'entrées c'est bien c'est
génial un énorme apport il ya un dvd qui
sort des 35 minutes en plus je les ai
vus alors il ya des trucs formidables
par contre la scène il ya tous les
sosies d'elvis qui qui déjeunent entre
eux pourquoi ça peut être gardé dans le
film ça parce qu'on a ça casse le rythme
moi je pense qu'au montage il faut être
sans pitié il faut pas trop s'écouter un
état d'âme
donc tout ce qui déborde je sais pas ce
qu'on pense y vivent mais je pense que
un film une comédie d'une heure trente
s'est bien quelle maturité déjà mais je
crois qu'il belle vista des choses c'est
dingue
alors aujourd'hui il ya deux mois que je
travaillais à l'adaptation d'amicalement
vôtre
j'avais un rôle pour agathe de la
fontaine faut s'arranger mais oui je te
dis je vais me rattraper voire tu vas
voir gaga tu n'es pas contente de
simpson interio folies d'hier non pas du
tout ah ben ouais les colères une conne
pourtant pour te prendre pour une conne
plus d'imagination
oui je suis d'accord mais il en a pas eu
sur ce coup là mais non comment je peux
faire comment attraper mais je vais voir
bella déjà non c'est pas mal à l'aise ou
non pas encore les bijoux faits après je
vais justement vahidi au bisou vous
publiez yann moix et chez grasset un
livre qui s'appelle partouze 1 100 e
sans eux et dans la typo moi que ça
c'est à dire que maintenant il ya c'est
la typo deux podiums quoi il ya
discussion il ya une typo yann moix là
sinon quand vous sortez un bouquin de
poésie par exemple transfusion c'est
encore la même typo vous aurez remarqué
que je restais un peu bloqué dans la
typographie flunch 1976 c'est vrai c'est
mon truc
alors le titre par tout son sens aux
yeux parce que vous dites que finalement
partout avec à eux ça fait un peu années
70 ça fait losier ça fait pompidou je
trouve que mon partout est un mot un peu
vieillot un peu ringard tout de suite
lancé
si nous sommes sérieux c'est mon temps
j'ai vu jusqu'à 20
ainsi rien cet été j'étais en vacances à
rome et j'envoie un texto à laurent
baffie qui je suis à rome je t'embrasse
moins de trente secondes plus tard je
reçois un texto de buffy qui je suis à
mykonos je t'encule
extrêmement déçu et est le seul fait don
weiss à l'aéro dynamise elle modernise
ses marges en sadique la mise au fait
mais comme naguib mahfouz l'écrivain
égyptien voilà deux non plus bah oui
c'est l'islam is un peu alors le pitch
bien il est très fort et très simple le
mariage c'est l'enfer c'est à table
mohammed atta est devenu intégrisme
musulman après avoir pris un râteau avec
une dénommée pamela wilshire quand il
était étudiant à l'université du caire
en 1989 1990 je me dis que les grands
chefs-d'oeuvre de la littérature sont
peut-être dû à une femme qui nous a
éconduit que les grandes
apocalypse sont aussi peut-être dû à une
douleur originel qui n'a pas été très
bien soigné alors la thèse du livre
s'est inventé fictivement une pamela
wilshire qui a éconduit mohammed atta
qui avait dit je ne veux pas de toi
alors le mec il écrivait des lettres etc
et un jour lui dit t'inquiète pas un
jour je vais te préparer quelque chose
exactement comme diderot le faisait dans
sa correspondance avec sophie volland
comme mitterrand a écrit à catherine
langeais pendant 50 ans je t'aime je
t'aime il est devenu présent la
république sans doute parce que
catherine langeais n'a pas voulu de lui
hélas ma thèse qui équipent terre très
personnel et aussi parce qu'un romancier
doit écrire des choses que les
journalistes n'écrivent pas parce
qu'elle correspond à une parcelle de
réalité qui est un peu oubliée écarté
c'est que mohammed atta levier un jour
le 10 septembre il appelle et lit écoute
je vais avoir ma revanche demain c'est
mon septembre ton quoi 11 septembre
parce que quand on prend le 8 octobre
1982 le 11 septembre 2001 il existait
déjà potentiellement elle n'était pas la
date qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
là maintenant il ya un trade marks 172
tmc devenu comme nike ou adidas en ces
temps de saint martin gray est alors la
thèse du truc c'est que mohamed attaoui
ben voilà demain je passe à la télé
regarde moi tu vas avoir de mes
nouvelles n'a pas voulu de moi
voilà ma revanche alors évidemment c'est
une espèce d'orchestration extrêmement
subjective de
d'un point de vue extrêmement farfelu
extrêmement névrotique parce que moi je
suis un grand grand grand brûlés de
l'amour et même si après j'ai eu plus de
succès avec les femmes je ne suis jamais
parvenu à complètement digéré les 2/3
râteau que j'ai subie quand jean 9 22
ans quoi et à partir de ça je faisais le
construire modestement une oeuvre
littéraire mohammed atta c'est votre
frère je sais mon frère de sang je pense
que pendant que moi je me branle et lui
prier il est né en 1968 tous les deux si
j'étais né au caire fragile comme je le
suis sorti mentalement il n'est pas
impossible que je me sois inventé un
islam perso un islam portable un islam
très très très personnelle et que
peut-être que j'aurais moi aussi verser
dans lequel ya alors là on rentre dans
une alternance entre deux types de
chapitre des chapitres sur mohammed atta
et et permet la wind fire et puis des
chapitres qui se passe dans une boîte de
partout ce qui s'appelle le recto verso
comprends pas pourquoi j'ai pris le
titre d'une émission de paul amar jeune
c'est vrai le pot avec le mal qui se
donne et c'est vrai il est très vexé
voulais pas non non non il vous encore
énormément de boîtes de préservatifs
pour m'excuser non je j'ai pas pensé du
tout honnêtement les descriptions de
boîte à partouze absolument génial
notamment j'ai aimé les les [ __ ]
célinienne et les [ __ ] proustienne
c'est quoi la différence et ans et que
j'ai remarqué que quand je me faisais
sucès il y avait j'ai remarqué un c'est
très personnel qui avait des filles qui
passé énormément de temps à faire des
allers venues à faire semblant de faire
jacques hull et puis en fait elles le
font pas et c'est donc ça prend un temps
fou ça s'étire ça revient sac sans sarah
thuram et sarah tueur et pour y aller
célinienne quitus parakou exact fait un
point d'exclamation non pas par grande
frayeur et s'est heurtée et le gland a
tous mal par exemple la sucent
célinienne ne viendrait jamais à l'idée
de lui lécher les coups il ya c'est vrai
alors que la course tienne c'est
michel je suis assez plutôt ses lignes à
nous projeter des je fais ce que je veux
mais
la juxtaposition peut parler gratuite en
fait deux choses d'abord j'ai
l'impression qu'une démocratisation
l'échangisme aujourd'hui et que le sexe
est devenu quelque chose de grande
consommation
et parce que j'ai je décris ça d'une
manière vraiment très consommatrice de
vraiment de d'énergie de consommation et
de frénésie sexuelle sans le moindre
sentiment est ce que j'ai remarqué en
boîte échangiste je suis allée dix fois
la dernière fois c'était d'ailleurs la
veille à la veille du 11 septembre 2001
j'ai pas vu beaucoup de bof j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de bourrins j'ai vraiment vu
des blessés de l'amour invite type qui
ne supporte plus les quelques minutes
nécessaires et obligatoires qui nous
oblige à les dire à une femme tu me
plaît j'ai envie de toi on dit moi je
suis un handicapé ça je suis incapable
draguer une fille ya rien de plus
violents sur terre que d'aller dire une
fille tu me plais moi je sais pas faire
ça alors évidemment les boîtes
échangistes c'est quelque chose où cette
cette douleur là est complètement abolie
on a un accès direct aux organismes
humains sont absolument génial
oui c'est le lapin alors le lapin c'est
pas 160 et 163 ce type était absolument
fascinant je l'avais baptisé le lapin un
peu trivialement jeu là vous mais ils
niquent est comme un malade sans jamais
faire de pause les seuls pause qu'il
s'autorisait c'était pour changer de
préservatifs parce qu en limant la même
fille pendant près de deux heures il
fallait de temps en temps faire
attention à ce que la capote ne brûle
pas avec les frottements incessant de la
[ __ ] contre la paroi vaginale ou halal
pas loin de lui dans ses parages ça
sentait vraiment comme une odeur de
caoutchouc brûlé comme quand on
conduisait quelques kilomètres en ayant
oublié de débloquer le frein à main
mais lui le lapin il ne freinait pas il
ne freinez jamais il attaque et il se
saccadé il donnait ses petits coups de
reins frénétique presque fou avec les
yeux ronds presque impassible d'un robot
et fracassé les côtes le cul les cuisses
les reins de tout ce qui lui passait
sous l'averse des petites et des ronds
des intellectuels et des vieilles des
rousses et des blacks des blacks rousse
les sublimes [ __ ] et des moches
relativement mal à l'aise des bombes et
des très peu sexy des vicieuse et des
scolaires des vendeuses de parfums et
des philosophes
j'avais remarqué une chose étrange chez
lui il notait jamais ses chaussettes
pour baiser il était complètement à poil
sauf les chaussettes cela lui conférer
une allure burlesque extrêmement peu
érotique les les femmes s'en fiche et ça
leur semble et un honneur de passer sous
le laminage le burinage de sa cage
l'usinage le bizutage le pilonnage le
pilotage de cela par la voilà ou alors
je moi j'ai vu le mec [ __ ] mais alors
il ya poil 117 et je me suis demandé ce
qu'il y avait dedans et alors il y avait
une espèce de petit rectangle chaud ça
je crois que c'est sa carte bleue mais
dans les boîtes échangistes
il n'y a pas de carte bleue on laissera
aux vestiaires mais en liquide voilà
et en fait le mec il avait des réserves
de préservatifs dans les chaussettes
pour pas les avoir des choix c'est ça
alors il ya plein de notation très très
juste sur l'amour par exemple les gens
qui j pl les faits cependant la levrette
vous dit que c'est une question
d'instinct et finalement s'appeler c'est
très étrange donc et moi j'étais là
dedans et puis au début un peu perdu ces
il faut bien comprendre c'est quand même
un univers auquel on s'habitue vite mais
les premières minutes sont quand même
assez intimidante et espèce de
complicité qui se nouent immédiatement
et je vois un type qui me regardent fait
un clin d'oeil il me dit le vrai de
plaques et il commença le fait c'est une
nana
j'apprends du vocabulaire le bread
claqué je savais pas que c'était un
vocabulaire je le cite comme le truc qui
m'a le plus traumatisées parce que je me
suis ramassé une fois un râteau dans une
boîte échangiste faut le faire parce que
tous ceux - décembre est censé pouvoir
avoir accès c'est bien n'importe quels
organismes biologiques humain j'arrive
tout timide peu nos habitants romantique
exactement et dès lors y avait une fille
qui était en train de se refaire une
levrette par un mec pendant ta vie ou
pas non claqué celle là classique la
syrie et elle était en empruntant sucer
un autre j'arrive tout bêtement il
imaginer le sud aux dérives et je
commence à mettre ma main sur son sein
gauche et la halle enlève le sexe qu'il
avait dans la bouche elle me regarde dit
non ça va pas être possible
elle se rebelle
c'est ça c'est ça qui est drôle dans le
bouquin ceux qui seront des râteaux
l'entrée c'est un échange ils
atteindront l échange d après vous
donner du plaisir
il a même pas le droit de donner du
plaisir ensuite il a une panne ce qui
donne dans une boîte échangiste est
quand même présent merdes en est à la
fin et quand il touche au but
il a une et jacques précoce quoi oui
c'est un monde qui à l'ère communiste
comme ça parce qu'on a l'impression que
tout le monde peut s'échanger que tout
le monde dans un grand bain démocratique
et des changes absolument égalitaire
c'est faux c'est ultra libérale une
boîte échangiste à dire que dans la
société actuelle c'est peut-être le plus
beau ou plus riches ou celui qui a le
plus de succès qui arrive à coucher que
les filles là bas c'est quand même c'est
horrible à dire mais c'est le sait celui
qui a la meilleure érection quoi et
c'est alors c'est en quelques secondes
que ça se passe les filles tout de suite
tac dont il ya quand même de l'ultra
libéralisme est une vraie concurrence
c'est un monde quand même assez
effrayant et alors le parallèle ignore
qui est le rapport entre entre mohammed
atta le personnage ne viennent pas que
j'inventais et les boîtes échangistes sa
maison que la thèse c'est que on en
direct non on ne parle jamais mais il y
a quand même une infime partie des
islamistes qui sont persuadés ils vont
avoir accès au sexe une fois le arriver
au paradis
bah ouais et donc je compare si vous
voulez quelques de vienne et grands
romantiques occidentaux ils vont baiser
dans les boîtes échangistes et les
grands romantiques islamistes leur accès
au sexy dans une autre boîte est changée
géante qui est le paradis des
terroristes paradis des terroristes
voilà il se met des bandelettes sur le
sexe pour le présent alors que à
jérusalem où le canton on trouve des
kamikazes ils ont des couches-culottes
comme les enfants pour préserver les
parties génitales et mohamed atta dans
son testament explique que personne n'a
le droit d'y toucher les parties vitales
qu'aucune femme enceinte n'a le droit
d'approcher son corps parce que la
première chose qu'il veut constater une
fois au paradis c'est le bon
fonctionnement de ces grenades
voilà alors le héros est très très fleur
bleue vin très romantique et et
finalement vous raconter qu'un jour vous
avez découvert que ça servait à rien
d'envoyer des lettres de 50 pages etc
il suffisait de dire aux femmes tu me
plaît je te veux que ça marchait j'ai
remarqué un titre extrêmement
personnelle que
lorsque j'écrivais des lettres de 150
pages en alexandrins aux filles elles se
foutait de ma gueule
et quand j'allais voir gentiment quand
j'allais les voir gentiment pour leur
dire tu me plais énormément j'ai envie
de toi
en général je parvenais à rencontrer à
les revoir et à leur faire l'amour quand
michel pas envie de faire le livre oui
bien sûr j'ai relevé moi je vois ça me
paraît toujours incroyable de partir
dans des trucs comme ça que j'ai
l'impression qu'à un côté un peu de
parler de cul c'est ça comme disait papa
le qui fait vendre
mais non c'est pas du tout genre il sait
ce que c'est le vrai sujet d'accord mais
c'est le sens de ces lignes que je
trouve génial à la médecine qui est la
culture et la religion ont créé une
femme entièrement théorique mais la page
non non c'est sa rue du champ d'anguille
j'avais chaud ben laden qui est très
bien écrit page 22 le deuxième
paragraphe est il de jan kounen
ce qui frappait surtout chez oussama ben
laden quand on le voyait sur ces
fameuses vidéos
c'était qu'il n'y avait chez lui
strictement rien d'antipathie qu il ne
dominait pas le monde d'une domination
aigre et raide comme un pouvoir mais
avec un sourire calme une grande douceur
il était symétriquement à l'opposé de
l'idée qu'on se fait généralement d'un
tyran
alors que les maîtres du monde qui
l'avait précédé avaient tous vécu dans
la terreur du couteau de l'assassin ou
du traître et avait régné dans la
paranoïa propre d'usurpateur oussama sûr
de sa légitimité avait l'air serein
enfantin loyal d'un bon droit bien
authentique bien dynastique bien
débonnaire une sorte de roi dagobert des
mille et une nuits sa domination lui
semblait couler de source
et bon enfant est d'autant plus
redoutable pour vous pour moi pour nous
tous
d'autant plus redoutable qu'elle n'était
pas seulement maîtresse du monde mais
maîtresse d'elle-même
il est pas il n'est pas agressif ben
laden dans les vidéos non il a inventé
une droguée ou non dans les vidéos oui
quand on le voit des gars
garçon très posé il dégage illégal il
est très bien à la télé je ne sais pas
l'apologie de ben laden
jeudi qu' ils dégagent ces réalités
c'est vrai orientale qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir les mêmes chez hitler
on n'a jamais le 8 l'air serein il est
plus entendu hurler les gens laden était
beaucoup plus petit oui ben laden et
parce que je crois qu il est vrai dans
la paranoïa
parce qu'il est conscient que d'une
certaine manière il a gagné en tout cas
il en est persuadé
donc je pense que dans le nazisme par
exemple qu'il est toujours la peur
d'avoir déjà perdu alors c'est tellement
énorme de bouquins cas - il ya un
journaliste qui rentre dans le bouquin
et qui dit mettez apparente des graves
et quadrillée comme ça y'a un truc qui
peut paraître scandaleux mais c'est pour
ça que je prends des gants pour le dire
que je fais intervenir un journaliste
qui sont fausses et c'est la chose
suivante le 11 septembre on est tous
d'accord que c'était quelque chose de
terrible d'horribles immonde ignoble
indescriptible mais voilà la petite
subtilité
pour nous c'était inimaginable on
septembre vous êtes bien d'accord on ne
peut pas l'imaginer mais si on se place
du point de vue des terroristes 1
pour eux c'est bien plus difficile de
réussir ce truc qu'ils ont imaginé
passer de la théorie de ce truc là à la
pratique de ce truc là c'est bien plus
difficile que d'avoir à l'imaginer
sésame jeudi s'il avait raté ça aurait
été un râteau de plus s'il avait raté ça
on se serait alors ils ont été un peu
large parce qu'ils ont pris deux tours
il y avait donc une tour de rattrapage
c'est une preuve de grandes lâche rien
non vous engueuler avec ce journaliste
est bien au rebond pas ça je parlais de
péguy qui s'est pris un râteau avec
blanche sera rafael de houellebecq juste
que houellebecq est un con hein je pense
que houellebecq est un con mais je les
assume
ouais je le dis tranquillement je pense
que on ne peut pas critiquer une
religion sans avoir été l'inspecter
l'étudier la regarde et il a eu des
jugements définitifs sur l'islam sur le
coran alors que je pense qu'il avait
absolument une méconnaissance totale la
religion ça passe par le respect quelle
que soit la religion et le moindre la
moindre des choses c'est d'aller lire au
moins les textes quoi et on peut pas
dire que l'islam cela marche ou ça
débile il y en a un autre qui trouve pas
grâce à vos yeux c'est ariel wizman
parce qu'il vous a dit un jour que
c'était les beaufs calé dans les boîtes
de tous j'ai rien dit j'ai vraiment rien
que dans les yvelines qui est plutôt un
type bien le problème et si on sait
qu'il a descendu la thèse que les boîtes
échangistes et héros c'était pour les
beaufs
et que les boîtes homo échangiste donc
les backrooms c'était pour les
intellectuels
je pense qu'au bout d'un moment arrive
wiesmann devrait choisir entre michel
foucault et jean pierre foucault mais
pas mélanger systématiquement les deux
voilà michel toi tu aime beaucoup il ya
je le trouve très très brillant et oui
on peut un peu à être étonné du du pij
de son bouquin ce parallèle est très
très déconcertant entre l'islam et les
boîtes de cul mais c'est
merveilleusement bien
je vais j'ai bien compris ce que moi
j'étais un long temps un grand frustré
sentimentale et sexuelle et ça m'a
marqué à vie quoi j'ai passé dix ans de
misère sentimentale et sexuelle mais
c'est formidable que tu arrivais
d'exprimer tu vois à l'heure où tout le
monde regarde tout ce que ça t'a apporté
à cit avait coûté le moment all in
j'ai pas envie j'adore son fils mais
j'ai pas envie de lire le liban ouais
vous attendez qu'il en fasse un film non
ça vous dit pas ça te dis toi moi j'ai
envie d'aller dans une boîte à partouze
avec le blouson alors les jarretelles
j'aimerais commerciaux ou les
jarretelles et zou pensée de son book à
agathe
je suis curieux animaux vous allez lyon
où c'est marrant ça peut donner des
idées en plus non sur l'isla nouveau
yann moix donc ça s'appelle par tous est
édité chez chez grasset est-ce que vous
êtes prêts pour une interview portrait
sexuelle haye